hey how's it going today we're in the
car yeah there's a little light not a
nice look I'm on my way to get my
haircut it's really faint rippity news I
might go a little nuts I might actually
get a lot cut off I might do the same
thing that I do
different people besides mature
hairstylist is where I can make it look
the same but a little bit better great
haircuts nice little highlights the ice
can tell a difference thumbs up if you
can't tell the difference definitely a
thumbs up because both of those things
are good things so right now I'm going
to film something with a bro and I'm
really excited because she's one of my
favorite people ever and we're doing a
little challenge video and Maddie's in
the backseat I'm gonna be dropping him
off at Matt's house and Matt Jenna are
gonna babysit him for the night to go to
Comic Con for a day baby's gonna go to
his his second parents house oh he's so
handsome I just like what come up from a
nap and he's like why are we going I
said we're gonna go see Jenna time for
the driving montage
there's our baby baby no we just filmed
a video ro was so productive like she
shoots videos very very far in advance
I'm super impressed but that I I'm like
I should say no and it's gone you know I
am on schedule I will say every year but
this year not the case yeah but this is
the first year that like I've been able
to film like stuff way in advance I'm so
impressed it's amazing so I can leave
travel word yeah go to like VidCon and
like events like that so well today we
did a really fun video I don't want to
tell them what it is or should we talk
about maybe we shouldn't tell them
anything else so by that point somebody
else might steal the idea oh okay it was
really fun it'll be out in September yes
so yeah stay tuned for that
mmm anything else going on haven't seen
you since a couple weeks ago be there oh
come on hmm ah look at them delay you're
like any trees over there
I mean I couldn't nibble on one of the
best things about having a dog is that
they are like mini vacuum they really
are yeah except they eat everything I'm
like that it's not edible
that's Plast yeah we have a list of
things that dogs can't eat me little ray
conniff it's the up grape so won't rain
them one of the things I didn't know
onions there's a whole list yep and
we're trained cookie that if something
falls on the floor she can't eat it
unless we say it's okay oh that's so
she'll just stare at it you just kind of
point at it like a little pointer like a
little little hunting dog that's like
you like we say so code should be like
one more my bill is mine a minute
why can't we for good to see this video
so you'll see it months but you buy what
you know no matter how many times I
clean it just it ends up a disaster
seconds after it's clean it's really
hard having a space where you live and
work like I'm tripping over things
pretty excited because I was gonna save
this for a tech Tuesday video but I need
it for tomorrow so I can't really do the
unboxing I'll probably do a proper video
on it but I'm hoping that's what's in
this box I need to find enough
first this better be what I think it is
no I'm still I'm still cut off anyway
GoPro announced a book bag a while back
and it's basically a GoPro integrated
book back out I'll do a full video
review on it but I wanted to do the
official unboxing which was I just did
it
water-resistant be a hero they say I'll
put a link in the description if you
don't want to get more information on
this not sponsored just a fan question
is my laptop gonna fit in here because
if it doesn't that's gonna be a
deal-breaker for tomorrow place for
GoPros another place to put some items I
don't think this is gonna be big enough
for my needs but this will be perfect
size for Pokemon hunting Wow
surprisingly this is a lot larger than I
thought when I opened this up okay there
we go
definitely not splattering it for a girl
there's a lot more cool things you can
do but I have to go to bed because I
gotta get up it at 5:30 15-inch MacBook
my god this is just such great news
good morning when I booked this train
last minute it's like yeah sure a 7:25
a.m. departure is not bad but the time
that you actually have to get there and
the time that I need to prepare even for
a day trip it's ridiculous you never
know what I'm gonna need I need to have
all of my items what if I need to shoot
a feature film I gotta be ready yeah we
can't read the play
baloney
babies managed in transition and now
we're obviously ago and so dire probably
should have left us
right
I'll bet you'll get it Fryeburg don't
get me wrong
say what you gotta say just say what you
gotta say like a satellite start you
gotta say what you gotta say
take it to the big save take it all
babies
me to San Diego and I cannot believe
what I caught on the train one of my
eggs hatched and I caught the sight
there and that's what we were trying to
catch the other day I think of my
previous vlog and so hopefully we can
find the site there when we went out and
the servers were down and I couldn't get
it and I ended up hatching a higher
level than Matt so I'm really excited
about it for those of you guys wondering
why I have a Samsung phone I am still a
Justine I don't work for Apple I don't
work for Samsung I just was using this
one because you're able to do really
cool screen recordings and it's super
easy and so what I'm using is the
Samsung s7 edge it's actually kind of
cool the glass is sort of rounded so
it's called the edge for a reason you
can see it on the edge this isn't the
first time I've had an Android phone
I've had a bunch of phones actually had
one of the first Google Nexus phones I
recently found it in my closet
and I was getting rid of a bunch of old
stuff and I was like you know what I'm
keeping this one so you just hit that
button hit record and it's screen
captures your phone anyway I'm probably
gonna go hunt some Pokemon here in a bit
it's not too hot in San Diego yet it's
still early so I'm gonna go to see what
we can see there's so many Kogi stops
and everything is like lit up like this
is crazy
they're everywhere I dropped a lure over
there though but nothing cuz it crashed